bienvenue chez serveur vivace je
m'appelle William Berthold et je produis
des légumes perpétuels
[Musique]
une plante vivace c'est une plante qui
va durer plus de 2 ans elle peut
disparaître l'hiver mais elle réapparaît
chaque printemps ce sont des ce qu'on
appelle des légumes perpétuels une fois
un certain type de chou ou d'oignons et
on le récolte sur plusieurs années il
s'en √ plus profondément que les légumes
annuels ils peuvent bénéficier de plus
facilement de l'eau par exemple les gens
commencent à se rendre compte de la
faiblesse de notre
système alimentaire et avoir des légumes
qui poussent tout seul dans notre jardin
ça permet d'avoir une certaine
résilience alimentaire
[Musique]
on peut voir ici l'épinard grimpant du
Caucase c'est un épinard voilà qui comme
son indique va venir grimper et
s'enrouler autour d'un grillage donc on
peut couper régulièrement les les tiges
et récolter les feuilles au fur et à
mesure pour les manger comme des
épinards
[Musique]
avant j'étais ingénieur développement de
produits j'ai toujours rêvé de
d'inventer des choses utiles et
finalement dans mon métier
je suis arrivé à la conclusion que
j'inventais plutôt des choses pour
répondre à des problèmes qu'on avait
nous-mêmes créés précédemment donc je me
suis dit quelque chose qui dont on aura
toujours besoin c'est de se nourrir j'ai
commencé et je suis d'ailleurs toujours
dans le jardin de mes parents
donc j'utilise cette petite surface pour
produire mes plantes en pot à partir de
pied-mère que j'ai à faire
[Musique]
donc c'est un chou qui fleurit pas du
coup on le multiplie par bouturage je le
bouture dans ma serre et ensuite c'est
rempoter ce qui me plaît c'est déjà de
découvrir de nouvelles variétés faire
découvrir aux gens qu'ils ont parfois
déjà même des légumes perpétuels dans
leur jardin et aussi leur en proposer
d'autres qu'on va pouvoir consommer
ailleurs dans le monde à l'avenir pour
développer mon activité j'aimerais
trouver un foncier pour m'installer ça
me permettra d'avoir assez de surface
pour vivre de ce métier et puis enfin de
mettre sur ces terrains-là des jardins
forêts que l'on pourra aussi visiter
pour s'initier aussi à la nouvelle
culture de légumes
[Musique]